Alright, welcome to problem set 4; this first problem we're going to be talking
a little bit about different kinds of search trees.
And let's go ahead and dive right in.
Now let's say we have a search tree, like so, but instead of branching twice at each level,
we want to say that it's going to branch four times.
So we have a search tree more like this, where at each level, we split four times.
So that means that, since this is a search tree,
there are four different possible paths we could go down at each different branch.
Now let's also say that this tree has a height of n/3,
where we're going to say that n is divisible by 3 just to keep things simpler.
So we have a whole lot of n nodes or leaves down here at the very end,
and let's just assume that there are a total of n/3 levels.
Now since this is a search tree, all of these end leaves here represent
a different possible solution that this search tree could come to.
So my question is how many solutions does such a search tree,
that splits at four times at each branch and has a height of n/3, actually go over?
How many solutions are there?
And please enter your answer in this box,
and let's go ahead and say that this is to the nth power--
we'll go ahead and give you that--and type this in to 3 decimal places, please.